it states that he didn't want to have
the Attorney General he didn't want to
have a role in trying to fire the
Attorney General so at this point I will
you bet Thank You mr. chairman
mr. Muller well first let me ask
unanimous consent mr. chairman to so he
didn't want to have the Attorney General
he didn't want to have a role in trying
to fire the Attorney General so at this
point I will you bet Thank You mr.
chairman mr. Muller well first let me
ask a unanimous consent mr. chairman to
semion about Comey said basically when
Comey called you drop everything you
were doing it gave examples you having
dinner with your wife and daughter Comey
calls you drop everything and go
if the article quoted Comey is saying if
a train were coming down the track and I
quote at least Bob Muller will be
standing on the tracks with me yeah you
and James Comey have been good friends
or were good friends for eight for many
years correct
oh we were business associates we both
started off in the Justice Department
about you were good friends you can work
together and not be friends but you were
home we were friends we were friends
that's my question thank you for getting
to the answer
now before you were appointed as special
counsel who and James Comey had been
good friends or were good friends for a
for many years correct
oh we were business associates he both
started off in the Justice Department
about you were good friends you can work
together and not be friends but you and
repellent were friends we were friends
that's my question thank you for getting
to the answer
now before you were appointed as special
counsel actually it goes to your
credibility and maybe you've been away
from the courtroom for a while
credibility is always relevant it's
always material and that goes for you
too
your witness before us let me ask you
when you talk to President Trump the day
before he appointed you or you were
appointed as special counsel you were
talking to him about FBI Director
position again
did he mention the flowering of James
not as a candidate I was asked did he
mentioned the firing of James Comey in
your discussion with him cannot never
pardon cannot remember it don't believe
so I'm not gonna be specific remember
but if he did you could been a fact
witness as to the president mentioned
the flowering of James not as a
candidate I was asked did he mentioned
the firing of James Comey in your
discussion with him cannot remember
pardon cannot remember it don't believe
so not gave me specific remember but if
he did you could been a fact witness as
to the president toward Donald Trump in
the summer of 2017 you didn't know
before he was hired I'm sorry what you
didn't know before he was hired for your
team you know what Peter struck hated
Trump okay you didn't know that before
he was made part of your team is that
what you say did not know that all right
when did you never learn when they did
find out I acted swiftly to have him
reassigned elsewhere in the AFL there's
some discussion about how swift that was
but when did you learn of the ongoing
affair he was having with Lisa Paige
about the same time a truck did you ever
order anybody to investigate the
deletion of all of their texts offer
their government phones once we found
that Peter structure was an author of
did you ever may I finish
order what you not answered my question
did you order an investigation and the
deletion and reformatting of their
government phones no there was an IG
investigation ongoing well listen now
regarding collusion or conspiracy you
didn't find evidence of any agreement
I'm quoting you among the Trump campaign
officials and any Russian linked
individuals to fear with our us election
correct or
so you also note in the report that an
element of any of those obstructions you
referenced requires a corrupt state of
mind correct corrupt intent correct
right and if somebody knows they did not
conspire with anybody from Russia to
affect the election and they see the big
Justice Department with people that hate
that person coming after him and then a
special counsel appointed who hires
dozen or more people that hate that
person and he knows he's innocent he's
not corruptly acting in order to see
that justice is done what he's doing is
not obstructing justice he is pursuing
justice and the fact that you ran it out
two years means news for pegylated lis
injustice I take it as time has expired
the witness may answer the question I
take your question the gentleman from
Florida director Muller I direct
Ramallah I'd like to get back to your
findings covering June of 2017 there was
a bombshell article that reported that
the President of the United States was
personally under investigation for
obstruction of justice and you said in
your report on page 90 volume 2 and I
quote news of the obstruction
investigation prompted the President to
calm again and seek to have the special
counsel removed close quote and then in
your report you wrote about multiple
calls from the President to White House
Counsel done again and regarding the
second call you wrote and I quote McGann
recalled that the president was more
direct saying something like call rod
tell rod that Muller has conflicts and
can't be special can't be the special
counsel again recall the president
telling him Muller has to go and call me
back when you do it director Muller
didn't again understand what the
president was ordering him to do I'd
direct you to the while we were written
in the
in terms of characterizing and is
feelings and in the report it says quote
Magan understood the president to be
saying that the special counsel had to
be removed
you also said on page 86 that quote
Magan consider the President's request
to be an inflection point and he wanted
to hit the brakes and he felt trapped
and Magan decided he had to resign Magan
took action to prepare to resign isn't
that correct
I direct you again to the report and in
fact that very day he went to the White
House and quoting a report you said
quote he then drove to the office to
pack his belongings and submit his
resignation letter
close quote that is directly from the
report it is and before he resigned
however he called the president's chief
of staff
Reince Priebus and he called the
president's senior advisor Steve Bannon
do you recall what began told them yeah
whatever he was said will be I will
appear in the repeat it is those quote
that is directly from the report it is
and before he resigned however he called
the president's chief of staff
Reince Priebus and he called the
president's senior advisor Steve Bannon
do you recall what began told them yeah
whatever hey what was said will be I
will appear in the report it is it was
wrong and he was prepared to resign over
it now these are extraordinarily
troubling events but you found a White
House Counsel began to be a credible
witness isn't that correct correct
director Muller the most important
question I have for you today is why
director Muller why did the President of
the United States want you fired I can't
answer that question
well I'm on page 89 in your report on
volume 2 you said and I quote
substantial evidence is why
director Muller why did the President of
the United States want you fired I can't
answer that question well I'm on page 89
in your report on volume 2 you said and
I quote substantial evidence obstruction
of justice
close quote director Muller you found
evidence as you lay out in your report
that the president wanted to fire you
because you were investigating him for
obstruction of justice isn't that
correct that's what it says in the
report yes and I go I stand behind the
report dr. Muller that shouldn't happen
in America no president should be able
to escape investigation by abusing his
power but that's what you testified to
in your report the president ordered
you fired the White House Counsel knew
it was wrong the president knew it was
wrong in your report says there's also
evidence of president we should not have
made those calls to McGann but the
president did it anyway
he did it anyway anyone else who
blatantly interfered with a criminal
investigation like yours would be
arrested and indicted on charges of
obstruction of justice director Muller
you determined that you were barred from
indicted a sitting president we've
already talked about that today that is
exactly why this committee must hold the
president accountable I yield back
gentleman yields back the gentlelady
from Alabama director Muller you just
said in response to two different lines
of questionings that you would refer but
as it relates to this firing discussion
that I would refer you to the report in
the way it was characterized in the
report importantly the president never
said fire Muller or in the investigation
and one doesn't necessitate the other
and McGann in
did not resign he stuck around for a
year and a half on March 24th attorney
general bar informed the committee that
he had received the special counsels
report and it was not until April 18th
that the Attorney General released the
report to Congress in the public when
you submitted your report to the
Attorney General did you deliver a
redacted version of the report so that
he would be able to release it to
Congress and the public without delay
pursuant to his announcement of his
intention to do so during his
confirmation hearing I'm not getting
engaged in the discussion about what
happened after the production of our
report had the Attorney General asked
you to provide a redacted version of the
report we worked on the redacted
versions together did he ask you for a
version where the grand jury material
was separated now can you get into
details is it your belief that an
unredacted version of the report could
be released to Congress or the public
that's in my purview rule 6 e material
why did you not take a similar action so
Congress could V this material we had a
process that we were operating on with
the Attorney General's Office are you
aware of any attorney general going to
court to receive similar permission to
unredacted not aware of that being done
the Attorney General released the
special counsels report with minimal
reactions to the public and any even
lesser redacted version to Congress did
you write the report with the
expectation that it would be released
publicly no we did not have an
expectation we rank the report
understanding that it was demanded by
the statute and would go to the Attorney
General for further proffer the review
and pursuant to the special council
regulations who is the only party that
must receive the charging decision
resulting from the special counsels
investigation with regard to the
President or
generally no generally Attorney General
at Attorney General bars and
confirmation hearing he made it clear
that he intended to release your report
to the public do you remember how much
of your report had been written at that
point you know were there significant
changes in tone or substance of the
report made after the announcement that
the report would be made available to
Congress in the public I can't get into
that during the Senate testimony of
Attorney General William bar Senate
Senator Kamala Harris asked mr. Barr if
he had looked at all the underlying
evidence that the special counsels team
had gathered he stated that he had not
so I'm gonna ask you did you personally
review all of the underlying evidence
gathered in your investigation well to
the extent that it came through the
special counsel's office yes
did anything single me member of your
team review all the underlying evidence
gathered during the course of your has
been recited here today substantial
amount of work was done whether it be
search warrant or or my point is is
there is no one member of the team that
looked at everything that's what I'm
trying to get it okay it's fair to say
that in an investigation is
comprehensive is yours it's normal that
different members of the team would have
reviewed different sets of documents and
few if anyone would have reviewed all of
the underlying thank you yes how many of
the approximately 500 interviews
conducted by the special conference - do
you attend personally very few on March
27 2009 teen you wrote a letter to the
Attorney General essentially completes
normal that different members of the
team would have reviewed different sets
of documents and few if anyone would
have reviewed all of the underlying
thank you yes how many of the
approximately 500 interviews conducted
by the special confidence do you attend
personally very few on March 27 2009
teen you wrote a letter to the Attorney
General
essentially complicit the result of our
investigation who wrote that March 27th
letter well I can't get into who wrote
it the internal deliberations you signed
it what I will say is a letter Stanford
seller okay why did you write a formal
letter since you had already called the
Attorney General to express those
concerns I can't get into that and turn
liberation did you authorize the letters
release to the media or was it leaked I
have no knowledge on either well you
went nearly two years without a leak why
was this letter leaked well III can't
get into it was this letter written and
late for the express purpose of
attempting to change the narrative about
the conclusions of your report and was
anything in attorney general bars letter
referred to as principled conclusions
answer the question please
and the question is yes you may answer
the question was anything an attorney
general bars letter referred to as the
principal conclusions letter dated March
24th inaccurate well I am NOT gonna get
into that time of the gentlelady has
expired the gentlelady from California
Thank You mr. chair director Muller as
you know we are focusing on five
obstruction episodes today I would like
to ask you about the second of those
five obstruction episodes it is in the
section of your report beginning on page
113 of volume 2 entitled quote the
president orders Magan to deny that the
president tried to fire the special
counsel end quote On January 25th 2018
the New York Times reported that quote
the president had ordered Magan to have
the Department of Justice fire you is
that correct correct and that story
related to the events you already
testified about here today
the president's calls to McCann to have
you removed
correct correct after the news broke did
the president go on TV and deny the
story do not know in fact the president
said quote fake news folks fake news a
typical New York Times fake story in
quote correct correct
but your investigation actually found
substantial evidence that McCann was
ordered by the president to fire you
correct yes
did the president's personal lawyer do
something the following day in response
to that news report I'd refer you to the
coverage of this in the report on page
114 quote On January 26 2018 the
president's
personal counsel called McGann's
attorney and said that the president
wanted McGann to put out a statement
denying that he had been asked to fire
the special counsel in quote did McCann
do what the president asked I refer you
to the report communicating through his
personal attorney McCann refused because
he said quote that the time story was
accurate in reporting that the president
wanted the special counsel removed isn't
that right I believe it is but I refer
you again to the report okay so mr.
McCann through his personal attorney
told the president that he is was not
going to lie is that right true
did the president drop the issue I refer
to the write-up of this in the report
okay next the president told the White
House staff secretary Rob Porter to try
to pressure McCann to make a false
denial is that correct that's correct
what did he actually direct Porter to do
and and I would send you back to the
report okay well on page 113 it says
quote the president been directed Porter
to tell him again to create a record to
make it clear that the president never
directed McCann to fire you in quote is
that correct that is as it's faintness
stated in the report and you found quote
the president said he wanted McGann to
write a letter to the file for our
records
correct correct and to be clear the
president is asking his White House
Counsel Don McCann to create a record
that McCann believed to be untrue while
you were in the midst of investigating
the president for obstruction of justice
correct generally correct and mr. McCann
was an important witness in that
investigation wasn't he
I'd have to say yes did the president
tell Porter to threaten the can if he
didn't create the written denial
aggravated a write-up of it in the
report in fact didn't the president say
quote and this is on page 116 if he
doesn't write a letter then maybe I'll
have to get rid of him in quote yes did
porter deliver that threat did the
president tell porter to threaten the
can if he didn't create the written
denial aggravated a write-up of it in
the report in fact didn't the president
say quote and this is on page 116 if he
doesn't write a letter then maybe i'll
have to get rid of him in quote yes did
porter deliver that threat what's in the
report well on page 116 it says the
president met him in the Oval Office
quote the president began the oval
office meeting by telling McCann that
the New York Times story didn't look
good and McCann needed to correct it is
that correct correct so as it's written
in the report yes the president asked
McCann whether he would do a correction
and McCann said no correct that's
accurate
well mr. Muller thank you for your
investigation uncovering this very
disturbing evidence my friend mr.
Richmond will have additional questions
on the subject however it is clear to me
if the president asked McCann whether he
would do a correction and McCann said no
correct that's accurate
well mr. Muller thank you for your
investigation
uncovering this very disturbing evidence
my friend mr. Richmond will have
additional questions on the subject
however it is clear to me if in that
interview mr. Mifsud lied you point this
out on page 193 volume 1 nipson denied
myths and also falsely stated in
addition Mifsud omitted three times he
lied to the FBI yet you didn't charge
him with the crime excuse me I'm sorry
did you say 193 Volume one 193 he lied
three times he pointed out in the report
why didn't you charge him with the crime
I can't get into internal deliberations
with regard who avoid or would not be
charged a lot of other people from make
up false table let's remember this let's
remember this in 2016 the FBI did
something they probably haven't done
before they spied on two American
citizens associated with a presidential
champagne George papadopolis and Carter
Paige with Carter Paige they went to the
FISA Court
they used the now-famous dossier as part
of the reason they were able to get the
warrant and spy on Carter page for a
better part of a year with mr.
Papadopoulos they didn't go to the court
they use human sources all kinds of from
about that moment happen ah police joins
the Trump campaign you got all these
people all around the world starting to
swirl around the names like Halper
downer Mifsud Thompson meeting in Rome
London all kinds of places the FBI even
sent even sent a lady posing as somebody
else went by the name as returned even
dispatched her to London to spy on mr.
Papadopoulos in one of these meetings
mr. Papadopoulos is talking to a foreign
diplomat and he tells the diplomat
Russians have dirt on Clinton that
diplomat then contacts the FBI and the
FBI opens an investigation based on that
fact you point this out on page one of
the report July 31st 2016 they opened
the investigation based on that piece of
information diplomat tells Papadopoulos
Russians have dirt excuse me
pappa topless tells the diplomat
Russians have dirt on Clinton diplomat
tells the FBI what I'm wondering is who
told Papadopoulos how did he find out it
can't get into the evidentiary file yes
you can because you talk about it you
gave us the answer page 192 of the
report you tell us who told him Joseph
nipson Joseph NIF's is a guy who told
Papadopoulos the mysterious professor
who lives in Rome in London
works at teach in two different
universities this is the guy who told
Papadopoulos he's the guy who starts at
all and when the FBI interviews him he
lies three times and yet you don't
charge him with a crime he charged rick
gates for false statements she charged
Paul Manafort for false statements he
charged Michael Cohen with false
statements he charged Michael Flynn a
three-star general with false statements
but the guy who puts the country through
this whole saga starts it all for three
years we've lived this now he lies
and you guys don't charge it and I'm
curious as to why well I can't get into
it and and it's obvious I think that we
can't get into charging decisions when
the FBI interviewed him in February FBI
interviews him in February when the
special counsel's office interviewed
Mifsud did he lie to you guys to get
into that did you interview Mifsud get
into that his myths at Western
intelligence of Russian intelligence
can't get into that a lot of things you
can't get into what's interesting you
can charge 13 Russians no one's ever
heard of no one's ever seen no one's
ever gonna hear of him no one's ever
gonna see him you can charge them you
can charge all kinds of people who are
around the president with false
statements but the guy who launches
every the guy who puts this whole story
in motion you can't charge him I think
that's amazing sir Knight
I'm not certain I agree with your
characterization well I'm reading from
your report Mifsud told Papadopoulos
Papadopoulos tells the diplomat the
diplomat tells the FBI the FBI opens the
investigation July 31st 2016 and here we
are three years later July of 2019 the
country's been put through this and the
central figure who launches it all lies
to us and you guys don't hunt him down
and interview him again and you don't
charge him with a crime now here's the
good news
here's the good news the president was
falsely accused of conspiracy the FBI
does a 10-month investigation and James
Comey when we deposed him a year ago
told us at that point they had nothing
you do a 22-month investigation the in
that 22 months you find no conspiracy
and what's the Democrats want to do they
want to keep investigating they want to
keep going maybe a better course of
action maybe a better course of action
is to figure out how the false
accusation started maybe it's to go back
and actually figure out why Joseph
nipson was lying to the FBI and here's
the good news here's the good news
that's exactly what Bill Bar is doing
and thank goodness for that that's
exactly what the Attorney General and
John Durham are doing they're gonna find
out why we went through this three years
timer saga and get to the bottom of
remember the gentleman has expired in a
moment we will take a very brief
five-minute break
first I asked everyone in the room to
please remain seated and quiet while the
witness exit through exits the room I I
know I also want to announce to those in
the audience that you may not be
guaranteed your seat if you leave the
hearing room at this time
very short recess
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
baby will come to order
people please take their seats before
the special counsel returns
yep
[Applause]
a gentleman from Louisiana mr. Richmond
Thank You mr. chairman mr. mother
congressman Dutch addressed Trump's
requests to Magan to fire you represent
Abbas talked about the President's
request of Magan to deny the fact that
the president made that request so I
want to pick up where they left off and
I want to pick up with the president
personal lawyer in fact there was
evidence that the president's personal
lawyer was alarmed at the prospect of
the president meeting with mr. McGann to
discuss mr. McCain's refusal to deny the
New York Times report about the
president trying to fire you correct
correct in fact the president's counsel
was so long by the prospect of the
president's meeting with McGann that he
called mr. McCain's counsel and said
that McGann could not resign no matter
what happened in the Oval Office that
day correct correct
so it's accurate to say that the
president knew that he was asking McGann
to deny facts that McGann quote had
repeatedly said were accurate unquote
isn't that right your investigation also
found quote by the time of the oval
attractive so it's accurate to say that
the president knew that he was asking
McGann to deny facts that McGann quote
had repeatedly said were accurate
unquote isn't that right your
investigation also found quote by the
time of the oval up were accurate isn't
that correct generally - I believe
that's on page 119 thank you in other
words the president was trying to force
him again to say something that McGann
did not believe to be true attack your I
want to
reference you to a slide in its own page
120 and it says substantial evidence
indicates that in repeatedly urging
Magan to dispute that he was ordered to
have the special counsel terminated the
president acted for the purpose of
influencing McGann's account in order to
deflect or prevent further scrutiny of
the president and it says substantial
evidence indicates that in repeatedly
urging Magan to dispute that he was
ordered to have the special counsel
terminated the president acted for the
purpose of influencing McGann's account
in order to deflect or prevent further
scrutiny of the president Lee would you
say that that action the president tried
to hamper the investigation by asking
staff to falsify records relevant to
your refer you to the report if I could
for review of that that episode thank
you also the president's attempt to get
Magan to create a false written record
were related to mr. Trump's concerns
about your obstruction of justice
inquiry correct I believe that to be
true in fact at that same oval office
meeting did the president also asked him
again why he had told quote why he had
two special counsel's office
investigators that the president told
him to have you removed
unquote and what was question to her if
I might let me go to the next one the
president quote criticized Magan for
telling your office about the June 17
2017 events when he told Magan to have
you removed
correct correct in other words the
president was criticized in his White
House Counsel for telling law
enforcement officials what he believed
to be the truth I can go back to the
text of the of the report well let me go
a little bit further would it have been
a crime if mr. McGann had lied to you
about the president
ordering him to fire you I don't want to
speculate okay is it true that you
charge multiple people associated with
the president for lying to you during
your investigation that is accurate
the president also complained that his
staff were taking notes during the
meeting about firearm again is that
correct that's what the report says yeah
the report but in fact it's completely
appropriate for the president's staff
especially his counsels to take notes
during a meeting correct the wording of
the report well thank you director
Muller for your investigation into
whether the president attempted to
obstruct justice by ordering his White
House Counsel dime again to lie to
protect the plot the report but in fact
it's completely appropriate for the
president's staff especially his
counsels to take notes during a meeting
correct
I rely on the wording of the report well
thank you director Muller for your
investigation into whether the president
attempted to obstruct justice by
ordering his White House Counsel dime
again to lie to protect the press of
Russia's disinformation campaign no as I
said in my opening statement I'm that
part of the building of the case was
predated me and by at least 10 months I
mean Paul manna for its alleged crimes
regarding tax evasion predated you you
had no problem charging them and matter
of fact it's her this Steele dossier
predated the Attorney General and he
didn't have any problem answering the
question when senator Cornyn asked the
Attorney General the exact question I
asked you director the Attorney General
said and I'm quoting no I can't state
that with confidence and that's one of
the areas I'm reviewing I'm concerned
about it and I don't think it's entirely
speculative now if something is not
entirely speculative then it must steal
dossier predated the Attorney General
and he didn't have any problem answering
the question when senator Cornyn asked
the Attorney General the exact question
I asked you director the Attorney
General said and I'm quoting no I can't
state that with confidence and that's
one of the areas I'm reviewing I'm
concerned about it and I don't think
it's entirely speculative now if
something is not in
speculative than it must help him that
there was an I'm quoting from the steel
dossier extensive evidence of conspiracy
between the Trump campaign team and the
Kremlin so here's my question
did Russians really tell that to
Christopher steel or did he just make it
all up and was he lying to the FBI let
me back up a second if I could and say
as I said earlier with regard to the
steel that's beyond my purview no it is
exactly your purview director Muller and
here's why only one of two things is
possible right either
steel made this whole thing up and there
were never any Russians telling him of
this vast criminal conspiracy that you
didn't find or Russians lied to steel
now if Russians were lying to steel to
undermine our confidence in our duly
elected president you'll that's beyond
my purview no it is exactly your purview
director Muller and here's why only one
of two things is possible right either
Steele made this whole thing up and
there were never any Russians telling
him of this vast criminal conspiracy
that you didn't find or Russians lied to
steel now if Russians were lying to
steel to undermine our confidence in our
duly elected president or quite
loquacious on other topics you write
3,500 words about the June 9 meeting
between the Trump campaign and Russian
lawyer vessel nets kya you write on page
103 of your report that the president's
legal team suggested and I'm quoting
from your report that the meeting might
have been a set up by individuals
working with the firm that produced the
steel reporting so I'm going to ask you
a very easy question director Muller on
the week of June 9 who did Russian
lawyer vessel Mnet's gaya meet with more
frequently
the Trump campaign or Glenn Simpson who
is functionally acting as an operative
for the Democratic National Committee
well what I think is missing here is the
fact that this is under investigation
other and elsewhere in the Justice
Department and if I can finish her and
if I could finish her and consequently
it's not within my purview a Department
of Justice and FBI should be responsive
to questions on this particular issue it
is absurd to suggest that a operative
for the Democrats was meeting with this
Russian lawyer the day before and the
day after the Trump Tower meeting
and yet that's not something you
reference now Glenn Simpson testified
under oath he had dinner with vessel
nets kya the day before and the day
after this meeting with the Trump team
do you have any basis as you sit here
today to believe that steel was lying as
I said before I say again it's not my
purview others are investigating what
you so it's not arrest view to look into
whether or not Steel's lying it's not
your purview to look into whether or not
anti-trump Russians are lying to steel
and it's not your purview to look at
whether or not Glenn Simpson was meeting
with the Russians the day before in the
day after you write 3500 words about the
Trump campaign meeting so I'm wondering
how these decisions are guided I look at
the inspector general's report I'm
citing from page 404 of the inspector
general's report it states page stated
Trump's not ever going to be President
right right struck replied no he's not
we'll stop it
also in the inspector general's report
there's someone identified as attorney
number two attorney number two this is
page 419 replied hell no and then added
viva la resistance attorney number two
in the inspector general's report and
struck both worked on your team didn't
they
pardon me yes they both worked on bright
struck replied no he's not we'll stop it
also in the inspector general's report
there's someone identified as attorney
number two attorney number two this is
page 419 replied hell no and then added
viva la resistance attorney number two
in the inspector general support and
struck both worked on your team didn't
they pardon me yes they both worked on
your nothing and so it seems to be that
when Glenn Simpson met with Russians
nothing when the Trump campaign met with
Russians 3500 words and maybe the reason
why there are this discrepancies and
what you focused on because the team
name of the gentleman has expired
pledged to stop Jeffries of New York is
recognized the mauler obstruction of
justice is a serious crime that strikes
at the core of an investigators effort
to find the truth correct correct the
crime of obstruction of justice has
three elements true true the first
element is an obstructive act correct
correct an obstructive act could include
taking an action that would delay or
interfere with an ongoing investigation
as set forth in volume 2 page 87
eighty-eight of your report true I'm
sorry could you again repeat the
question an obstructive act could
include taking an action that would
delay or interfere with an ongoing
investigation that's true your
investigation found evidence that
President Trump took steps to terminate
the special counsel correct correct mr.
Muller does ordering determination of
the head of a criminal investigation
constitute an obstructive act that would
be to the report let me refer you to
page 87 and 88 of volume 2 where you
conclude the attempt to remove the
special counsel would qualify as an
obstructive act if it would naturally
obstruct the investigation and any grand
jury proceedings that might flow from
the inquiry correct yes I've got that
now thank you thank you
the second element of obstruction of
justice is the presence of an
obstructive act and connection with an
official proceeding true does the
special counsels criminal investigation
into the potential wrongdoing of Donald
Trump constitute an official proceeding
and that's an area which I cannot get
into okay President Trump tweeted on
June 16th 2017 quote I am being
investigated for firing the FBI director
by the man who told me to fire the FBI
director witch-hunt the June 16th tweet
just read was cited on page 89 and
volume 2 constitutes a public
acknowledgement by President Trump that
he was under criminal investigation
correct I think generally correct one
day later on Saturday June 17th
President Trump called White House
Counsel Don Magan at home and directed
him to fire the Special Counsel troop I
believed to be true I think we've been I
may have stated in response to questions
some that is correct a president Trump
told Don Magan quote Muller
to go close quote correct
correct your report found on page 89
volume 2 that substantial evidence
indicates that by June 17th the
president knew his conduct was under
investigation by a federal prosecutor
who could present any evidence of
federal crimes to a grand jury true true
the third element Muller has to go close
quote
correct correct your report found on
page 89 volume 2 that substantial
evidence indicates that by June 17th the
president knew his conduct was under
investigation by a federal prosecutor
who could present any evidence of
federal crimes to a grand jury true true
the third element point through the
three elements of proof of the
obstruction of justice charges when the
fact that matter is we got excuse me
just one second well thank you mr. Malla
let me let me move on in the interest of
time upon learning about the appointment
of the special counsel your
investigation found that Donald Trump
stated to the then Attorney General
quote oh my god this is terrible this is
the end of my presidency um EFT is that
correct correct is it fair to say that
Donald Trump viewed the special counsels
investigation into his conduct as
adverse to his own interests I think a
general eight is true the investigation
found evidence your investigation found
that Donald Trump stated to the then
Attorney General quote oh my god this is
terrible this is the end of my
presidency
um EFT is that correct correct is it
fair to say that Donald Trump you the
Special Counsel investigation into his
conduct as adverse to his own interests
I think a generator is true the
investigation found evidence we urged
McGann to dispute that he was ordered to
have the special counsel terminated
correct correct
the investigation found substantial
evidence that when the President ordered
done began to fire the Special Counsel
and then lie about it Donald Trump one
committed an obstructive act two
connected to an official proceeding
three did so with corrupt intent those
are the elements
obstruction of justice this is the
United States of America no one is above
the law no one the President must be
held accountable one way or the other
let me let me just say if I might I
don't subscribe necessarily to your the
way you analyze that I'm not seeing a
ton of the ballpark but I'm not
supportive of that analytical charge
thank you
Thank You mr. chairman mr. melih over
here hi hi I want to start by thanking
you for your service
you joined the Marines and let a rifle
platoon in Vietnam where you earned a
Bronze Star Purple Heart and other
commendations you served as an assistant
United States attorney leading the
Homicide Unit here in DC US Attorney for
the District of Massachusetts and later
Northern District of California
assistant Turney general for DOJ is
Criminal Division and the FBI director
so thank you I appreciate that but
having reviewed your biography it
puzzles me why you handled your duties
in this case the way you did the report
contradicts what you taught young
attorneys at the Department of Justice
including to ensure that every defendant
is treated fairly or as justice
Sutherland said in the Berger case a
prosecutor is not the representative of
an ordinary party to a controversy but
of a sovereignty whose interest in a
criminal prosecution is not that it
shall win a case but that justice shall
be done and that the prosecutor may
strike hard blows but he is not at
liberty to strike foul ones by listing
the 10 factual situations and not
reaching a conclusion about the merits
of the case you unfairly shifted the
burden of proof to the president forcing
him to prove his innocence while denying
him a legal form to do so and I've never
heard of a prosecutor declining a case
and then holding a press conference to
talk about the defendant you noted eight
times in your report that you had a
legal duty under the regulations to
either prosecute or decline charges
despite this you disregarded that duty
as a former prosecutor I'm also troubled
with your legal analysis you discuss ten
separate factual it patterns involving
alleged obstruction and then you fail to
separately apply the elements
of the applicable statutes I looked at
the the ten factual situations and I
read the case law and I have to tell you
just looking at the Flint matter for
example the the four statutes that you
cited for a possible obstruction 1503
1505 1512 B 3 and 1512 C 2 when I look
at those concerning the Flint matter
1503 is inapplicable because it wasn't a
grand jury or trial jury impaneled and
director Comey was not an officer of the
court as defined by the statute section
1505 criminalizes acts that would
obstruct or impede administrative
proceeding 1512 B 3 and 1512 C 2 when I
look at those concerning the Flynn
matter 1503 is inapplicable because
there wasn't a grand jury or trial jury
impaneled and director Comey was not an
officer of the court as defined by the
statute section 1505 criminalizes acts
that would obstruct or impede
administrative proceedings team 12 C 2
talks about tampering with the record of
and as Joe Biden described the statute
as is being debated on the Senate floor
he called this a statute criminalizing
document shredding and there's nothing
in the in your report that alleges that
the president destroyed any to any
evidence so what I have to ask you and
what I think people are working around
in this hearing is let me lay a little
foundation for the ethical rules require
their prosecutor have a reasonable
probability of conviction to bring a
charge is that correct
totally accurate okay and the
regulations concerning your job as
Special Counsel state that your job is
to provide the Attorney General with a
confidential report explaining the
prosecution or declination decisions
reached by your office you recommend a
declining prosecution of President Trump
and anyone associated with his campaign
because there was insufficient evidence
to convict for a charge of conspiracy
with Russian and Ferris in the 2016
election is that fair fair was there
sufficient evidence to convict president
Trump or anyone
with obstruction of justice we did not
make that calculation how could you not
have meet the calculation is regular
Elsi opinion the OLC opinion office of
legal counsel indicates that we cannot
indict a sitting president so one of the
tools that a prosecutor would use is not
there okay but but let me just stop you
made the decision on the Russian
interference you you couldn't have
ignited the President on that and you
made the decision on that but when it
came to obstruction you threw a bunch of
stuff up against the wall to see what
would stick and that is I would not
agree to that characterization at all
what we did is provide to the Attorney
General in the form of a confidential
memorandum our understanding of the case
those cases that were brought those
cases order declined and the one case
where the president cannot be charged
with a crime okay
but the could you charge the president
with a trim' after he left office yes
you believe that he committed you could
charge the president United States with
obstruction of justice after he left
office yes ethically under the ethical
standards well I'm not certain examine
looked at the ethical standards but the
OLC offend opinion says that the
prosecutor why cannot bring a charge
against a sitting president nonetheless
I can to continue the investigation to
see if there any other person to might
be drawn into the conspiracy time of the
gentleman has expired the gentleman from
Rhode Island director director as you
know we are specifically focusing on
five separate obstruction episodes here
today I'd like to ask you about the
third episode it's the section of your
report entitled the president's efforts
to curtail the Special Counsel
investigation beginning at page 90 and
by kartell you mean limit correct my
colleagues have walked through how the
president tried to have you fired
through the White House Counsel and
because mr. McGann refused the order the
president asked others to help limit
your investigation is that correct
correct
and was corey lewandowski one such
individual Special Counsel investigation
beginning at page 90 and by kartell you
mean limit correct my colleagues have
walked through how the president
have you fired through the White House
Counsel and because mr. McGann refused
the order the president asked others to
help limit your investigation is that
correct correct and was corey
lewandowski one such individual again
can you remind me of the second volume
yes a meeting in the Oval Office between
mr. Lewandowski and the president okay
and that was just two days after the
president called on McGann at home and
ordered him to fire you is that correct
apparently so so right after his White
House Counsel mr. McGann refused to
follow the president's order to fire you
the president came up with a new plan
and that was to go around all of his
senior advisors and government aides to
have a private citizen try to limit your
investigation what did the president
tell mr. Lewandowski to do do you recall
he told him he dictated a message to mr.
Lewandowski
for Train General Sessions and asked him
to write it down is that correct true
and do you or did you and your team see
this handwritten message and that was to
go around all of his senior advisors and
government aides to have a private
citizen try to limit your investigation
what did the president tell mr.
Lewandowski to do do you recall he told
him he dictated a message to mr.
Lewandowski for Train General Sessions
and asked him to write it down is that
correct true and do you or did you and
your team see this handwritten message
hey that thank you yes it is in other
words mr. Lewandowski a private citizen
was instructed by the President of the
United States to deliver a message from
the President to the Attorney General
that directed him to limit your
investigation correct correct and at
this time mr. sessions was still recused
from oversight of your investigation
correct I'm sorry could you see Sir John
was recused from over the Attorney
General would have had to violate his
own department's rules in order to
comply with the president's order
correct well I'm not gonna get into the
subsidiary details I just refer you
again to page 91 92 of the report and if
the Attorney General had followed
through with the president's press mr.
Malla it would have effectively ended
your investigation into the president
and his campaign as you note on page 97
correct thank you
you page 97 you write I quote taken
together the president's two
Actives indicate that sessions was being
instructed to tell the special council
to end the existing investigation into
the president and his campaign with the
special council being permitted to move
forward with investigating election
meddling for future elections is that
correct
generally true yes sir and it's an
unsuccessful attempt to obstruct justice
is still a crime is that correct that is
correct and mr. Lewandowski tried to
meet with the Attorney General is that
right
true and he tried to meet with him in
his office so he would be certain it
wasn't a public log of the visit
according to what we gathered for the
report and the meeting never happened
and the president raised the issue again
with mr. Lewandowski and this time he
said and I quote if sessions does not
meet with you
Lewandowski should tell sessions he was
fired correct correct
so immediately following the meeting
with the president Lewandowski then
asked mr. Dearborne to deliver the
message who's the former chief of staff
to mr. sessions and misshapen and the
president raised the issue again with
mr. Lewandowski and this time he said
and I quote if sessions does not meet
with you Lewandowski should tell
sessions he was fired
correct correct so immediately following
the meeting with the president
Lewandowski then asked mr. Dearborne to
deliver the message who's the former
chief of staff to mr. sessions and mr.
Dearborne refuses deliver it because he
doesn't feel comfortable isn't that
correct
generally correct yes so just so we're
clear mr. mark two days after the White
House Counsel Donegan refused to carry
out the president's order to fire you
the president directed a private citizen
to tell the Attorney General of the
United States who was recused at the
time to limit your investigation to
future elections those investigation to
future elections interference was
intended to prevent further
investigative scrutiny of the president
and his campaign conduct is that correct
generally and so mr. Maurer you have
seen a letter where a thousand former
Republican and Democratic federal
prosecutors have read your report and
said anyone but the president committed
those acts would be charged with
obstruction investigation to future
elections interference was intended to
prevent further investigative scrutiny
of the president and his campaign
conduct is that
correct generally and so mr. Mahler you
have seen a letter where a thousand
former Republican and Democratic federal
prosecutors have read your report and
said anyone but the president who
committed those acts would be charged
with obstruction of justice do you agree
with those former colleagues a thousand
prosecutors came to that conclusion
those prosecutors Thank You mr. chairman
over here thanks mr. mr. Muller you guys
you're team wrote in the report quote on
this is the top of page 2 volume can you
remind me which paragraph here at
Burlington off the page 2 1 2 1 okay and
exactly which paragraph are you looking
at on investigation did not establish of
course I see it yes what was your
question my question now is when did you
personally reach that conclusion well we
were ongoing for two years right you
aren't going he wrote it at some point
during that two-year period but at some
point you had to come to conclusion that
that I don't think there's a clue that
there's not a conspiracy going on here
there was no conspiracy between this
president and I'm not talking about the
rest of the president's team time at
this approach that conclusion well we
were ongoing for two years right you
aren't going he wrote it at some point
during that two-year period but at some
point you had to come to conclusion that
that I don't think there's a clue that
there's not a conspiracy going on here
there was no conspiracy between this
president I'm not talking about the rest
of the president's team time at this
president at a particular point in time
but it was sometime well before you
wrote the report fair enough
I mean you wrote the report dealing with
a whole myriad of issues certainly at
some time prior to that report is when
you reach the decision that okay with
with regard to the President himself I
don't find anything here fair enough
well I'm not certain I do agree with
that you waited till the last minute
when you were actually right in port
city okay no but there there are various
aspects of the development of it
sure and that's my point there are
various aspects that are that happened
but somewhere along the pike you will
come to the conclusion there's no
there-there for this defendant and that
right so I can't speak you can't so you
can't say win fair enough so so you know
I'm not done I'm I'm asking the the
sworn witness mr. mr. Mulder evidence
suggests that on May 10th 2017 at
approximately 7:45 a.m. six days before
the dag Deputy Attorney General
appointed you special counsel mr. Rosen
Stein called you and mentioned the
appointment of a special counsel not not
necessarily that you'd be appointed but
that you had a discussion of that is
that is that true
may 10th 2017 I don't know I don't have
any knowledge of that occurring you
don't have any knowledge or you don't
recall I don't have any knowledge
evidence also just given that what I saw
you do
are you questioning that yeah well I
just find it intriguing let me just tell
you that there's evidence that suggests
that that phone call took place and that
that's what was said so let's move to
the next question evidence suggest that
also on May 12th 2017 five days before
the dag appointed you special counsel
you met with mr. Rosen Stein in person
did you discuss the appointment of a
special counsel then not necessarily
that you but that there would be a
special counsel I've gone into waters
that don't allow me to give you an
answer to that particular question it
relates to the internal discussions he
would have in terms of indicted and
individual his men do the indictment has
to do with special counsel and whether
you discussed that with mr. Rosen Stein
evidence also suggests that I made 13
four days before you were playing
special counsel you met with attorney
former attorney General Sessions and
Rosen Stein and you spoke about special
counsel do you remember that no okay and
on May 16th the day before you were
appointed special counsel you met with
the president and rod Rosenstein do you
remember having that meeting yes and
discussion of the position of the FBI
director took place do you remember that
yes and did you discuss at any time in
that meeting mr. commis termination
no did you discuss at any time in that
meeting the potential appointment of a
special counsel not necessarily you but
just in general terms I can't get into
the discussions on that how many times
did you speak to mr. Rosen side before
May 17th was the day you got appointed
regarding an appointment of special
counsel how many times prior to that did
you did you discuss how many times you
said because you don't recall her or you
or you just I do not recall okay thank
you
how many times did you speak with mr.
Comey about any investigations
pertaining to Russia prior to in May 17
2017 did you have any at all zero
pointed regarding an appointment of
special counsel how many times prior to
that did you did you discuss how many
times you said because you don't recall
her or you or you just I do not recall
okay thank you
how many times did you speak with mr.
Comey about any investigations
pertaining to arrested prior to in May
17 2017 did you have any at all zero
twelve thousand years of federal service
wrote a letter regarding the president's
conduct are you familiar with that
letter I've read about that letter yes
and some of the individuals who signed
that letter the statement of former
prosecutors are people you worked with
is that right quite probably yes people
that you respect quite probably yes and
in that letter they said all of this
conduct trying to control and impede the
investigation against the president by
leveraging his authority over others is
similar to conduct we have seen charged
against other public officials and
people in powerful positions are they
wrong they have a different case do you
want to sign that letter direct Ramona
they have a different case director
Muller thank you for your service going
all the way back to the 60s when you
courageously served in Vietnam because I
have a seat on the Intelligence
Committee I'll have questions later and
because of our limited time I will ask
to enter this letter into the record
under unanimous consent that until my
colleague from California mr. Liu thank
you director Muller for your long
history of service to our country
including your surveys as a Marine where
you earned a Bronze Star with a V device
I'd like to now turn
to the elements of obstruction justice
as applied to the president's attempts
to curtail your investigation the first
element of obstruction of justice
requires an obstructive act correct
correct I'd like to direct you to page
97 of volume 2 of your report and you
wrote there on page 97 quote sessions
was being instructed to tell the special
counsel to end the existing
investigation into the president and his
campaign unquote that's in the report
correct correct that would be evidence
of an obstructive act because it would
naturally obstruct their investigation
correct correct okay let's turn now to
the second element of the crime of
social justice which requires a nexus to
an official proceeding again I'm going
to direct you to page 97 the same page
of volume 2 and you wrote quote by the
time of the president's initial
one-on-one meeting with Lewandowski on
June 1927 struct their investigation
correct correct
okay let's turn now to the second
element of the crime of social justice
which requires a nexus to an official
proceeding again I'm going to direct you
to the page 97 the same page of volume 2
and you wrote quote by the time of the
president's initial one-on-one meeting
with Lewandowski On June 1927 lists on
that same page page 97 do you see where
there's the intent section on that page
Betsy would you be willing to read the
first sentence and that was starting
with substantial evidence indicates that
the president if you could read that
first sentence would you believe that
I'm happy to have you written okay I
will read in that you wrote quotes on
that same page page 97 do you see where
there's the intent section on that page
let's see would you be willing to read
the first sentence and that was starting
with substantial evidence indicates that
the president if you could read that
first sentence would you believe that
I'm happy to have you written okay I
were reading that you wrote quote
substantial evidence indicates that the
president's effort to have sessions
limit the scope of the special counsels
investigation to future election
interference
was intended to prevent further
investigative scrutiny of the presidents
and his campaigns conduct unquote that's
in the report correct that is in the
report and I rely what's in the report
to lewandowski's to tell jeff sessions
to limit your investigation so that he
you stop investigating the president I
believe you're reasonable person looking
at these facts could conclude that all
three elements of the crime of
assumption justice have been met and I'd
like to ask you the reason again that
you did not indict Donald Trump is
because of OLC opinion stating that you
cannot indict a sitting president
correct that is correct
the fact that their order is by the
president were not carried out that is
not a defense to absorption justice
because a statute itself is quite broad
it says that as long as you endeavor or
attempt to obstruct your indict Donald
Trump is because of OLC opinion stating
that you cannot a date a sitting
president correct
that is correct the fact that their
order is by the president were not
carried out that is not a defense to
absorption justice because a statute
itself is quite broad it says that as
long as you endeavor or attempt to
obstruct jobs tampering zuv michael
cohen and paul manna for it all that the
only thing i want to add is that i'm
going through the elements with you do
not mean or does not mean that I
subscribe to the what you're trying to
prove through those elements the timing
the gentleman has expired the gentlelady
from Arizona
I'm sorry gentleman from California
Thank You mr. chairman over here thanks
for joining us today
you had three discussions with rod
Rosenstein about your appointment of
special counsel may 10th may 12th in May
13th correct if you say so I have no
reason to dispute that then you met with
the president on the 16th with rod
Rosenstein present and then on the 17th
you were formally appointed his special
counsel were you meeting with the
president on the 16th with knowledge
that you were under consideration for
appointment of special counsel I did not
believe
was under consideration for council the
I had served two terms as FBI prisoner
the answer's no been formally appointed
his special counsel were you meeting
with the president on the 16th with
knowledge that you were under
consideration for appointment of special
counsel I did not believe I was under
consideration for counsel the I had
served two terms as FBI prisoner the
answer is no number seventeen to twenty
seventeen November 2017 the edited
version in your report makes it appear
that he was improperly asking for
confidential information and that's all
we know from your report except that the
judge in the Flynn case ordered the
entire transcript released in which Dowd
makes it crystal clear that's not what
he was suggesting so my question is why
did you edit the transcript to hide the
exculpatory part of the message I'm not
certain I agree with your
characterization as we did anything to
hide well you admit you omitted it you
you quoted the part where he says we
need some kind of heads-up just for the
sake protecting all of our interests if
we can but you will mitad the portion
where he says without giving up any
confidential information well I'm not
going to go further transcript to hide
the exculpatory part of the message I
have matter now agree with your
characterization as we did anything to
hide well you admit you omitted it you
you quoted the part where he says we
need some kind of heads-up just for the
sake protecting all of our interests if
we can but you omitted the portion where
he says without giving up any
confidential information well I'm not
going to go further
US State Department intelligence source
yet nowhere in your report is he so
identified why was that fact I don't I
don't necessarily credit what you're
saying occurred were you aware that
clinic was a I go into a department now
I'm not gonna go in the ins and outs of
what we had in the court region or in
the course Konstantin Klem mnek pardon
did you interview Konstantin Clinic I
can't go into the discussion of our
investigative moves and yet that is
the basis of your report again the
problem we're having is we have to rely
on your report for an accurate
reflection of the evidence and we're
starting to find out that that's not
true for example you your report
famously links Russian internet troll
farms with the Russian government yet
adhering on May 28 and the Concord
Management IRA prosecution that you
initiated the judge excoriated both you
and mr. Barr for producing no evidence
to support this claim why did you
suggest Russia was responsible for the
12 farms when in court you've been
unable to produce any evidence to
support it I already have but you have
left the clear impression throughout the
country through your report that it was
the Russian government behind the troll
farms and yet when you're called upon to
provide actual evidence in court you
fail to do so well I would again dispute
your characterization of what occurred
in that preset in that proceeding in
fact the judge considering considered
holding prosecutors in criminal contempt
she backed off only after your hastily
called press conference the next day in
which you retroactively Lee made the
distinction between the Russian
government and the Russia troll farms
did your press conference of May 29th
have anything to do with the threat to
hold your prosecutors in contempt the
previous day for publicly
misrepresenting the evidence what was
the question the question is did your
May 29th press conference have anything
to do with the fact that the previous
day the judge threatened to hold your
prosecutors in contempt for
misrepresenting evidence no no they the
fundamental problem is as I said we've
got to take your word your team
faithfully accurately impartially and
completely described all of the
underlying evidence in the malla report
and we're finding more and more
instances where this just isn't the case
and it's starting to look like you know
having desperately tried and failed to
make a legal case against the president
you made a political case instead you
put it in a paper sack lit it on fire
dropped it on our porch rang the door
and ran I don't think you reviewed a
report that is as thorough as fair as
consistent as the report that we have in
front of us then why is contra dime of
the gentleman has expired come in from
Maryland is recognized director Muller
let's go to a fourth episode of
obstruction of justice in the form of a
witness tampering which is urging
witnesses not to cooperate with law
enforcement either by persuading them or
intimidating them witness tampering is a
felony punishable by 20 years in prison
you found evidence that the president
engaged in efforts and I quote to
encourage witnesses not to cooperate
with the investigation is that right
that's correct do you have a citation
I'm page 7 on volume 2 now one of these
witnesses was Michael Cohen the
president's personal lawyer who
ultimately pled guilty to campaign
violations based on secret hush money
payments to two women the president knew
and also to lie in Congress lying to
Congress about the hope for 1 billion
dollar Trump Tower deal after the FBI
searched Cohen's home the president
called him up personally he said to
check in and told him to quote hang in
there and stay strong is that right do
you remember finding that if it's in the
report
as stated yes it is right yes also in
the report actually are a series of
calls made by other friends of the
president one reached out to say he was
with the boss in mar-a-lago and the
president said he loves you his name is
redacted another redacted friend called
to say the boss loves you and a third
redacted friend called to say everyone
knows the boss has your back do you
remember finding that sequence of is
when the news and in fact Cohen said
that following the receipt of these
messages I'm quoting here page 147
volume 2 he believed he had the support
of the White House if he continued to
tow the party line and he determined to
stay on message and be part of the team
that's it page 147 remember generally
finding the other way as well and Robert
Castello a lawyer close to the
president's legal team email cohen to
say quote you are loved they are in our
corner sleep well tonight and you have
friends in high places and that's up on
the screen page 147 you remember
supporting that okay now when the news
first broke that Cohen had arranged
payoff to stormy Daniels Cohen
faithfully stuck to this party line
he said that publicly that neither the
Trump Organization nor the Trump
campaign was a party to the transaction
and neither reimbursed him Trump's
personal attorney at that point quickly
texted Cohen to say quote client says
thank you for what you do mr. Muller who
is the capital C client thanking Cohen
for what he does can't speak to that
okay the assumption in the context
suggests very strongly as president
Trump I can't speak to that okay
Cohen later broke and pled guilty to
campaign finance offenses and admitted
fully they were made quote at the
direction of candidate Trump do you
remember that yes after Cohen's guilty
plead the president suddenly changed his
tune towards mr. Cohen didn't he I would
say I rely on what's in the report well
he made the suggestion that Cohen family
members had committed crimes he targeted
for example Cohen's father-in-law and
repeatedly suggested that he was guilty
of committing crimes right I generally
accurate okay on page 154 you give a
powerful summary of these changing
dynamics and you said I'm happy to have
you read it found happy to do it if not
I've in front of me thank you
what would you like to read it I would
can you read it out loud to everybody I
would be happy to have you read it up
okay will read at the same time the
evidence concerning this sequence of
events could support an inference that
the president used inducements in the
form of positive messages in an effort
to get Cohen not to cooperate and then
try to me thank you what would you like
to read it
I would can you read it out loud to
everybody I would be happy to have you
read it okay farewell read at the same
time the evidence concerning this
sequence
events could support an inference that
the president used inducements in the
form of positive messages in an effort
to get Cohen
not to cooperate and then churches that
in America no person is so high as to be
above the law I yield back mr. chairman
Thank You mr. chairman
just recently mr. Muller you said mr.
Liu was asking you questions and mr.
Liu's question I quote the reason you
didn't indict the president is because
of the OLC opinion and you answered that
is correct but that is not what you said
in the report and it's not what you told
attorney general Barr and in fact in a
joint statement that you released with
DOJ on May 29th after your press
conference to her offered your office
issued a joint statement with the
Department of Justice that said the
Attorney General has previously stated
that the special counsel repeatedly
affirmed that he was not saying that but
for the OLC opinion he would have found
the president obstructed justice the
special counsel does report in his
statement today made clear that the
office concluded it would not reach a
determination one way or the other
whether the president committed a crime
there is no conflict between these
statements so mr. Miller do you stand by
your joint statement with DOJ that you
issued on May 29th as you sit here today
I would have to look at it more closely
before I said I agree with it well so I
you know my conclusion is that what you
told mr. Liu really contradicts what you
said in the report and specifically what
you said apparently repeatedly to
attorney general bar that and then you
issued a joint statement on May 29th
saying that the Attorney General has
previously stated that the special
counsel repeatedly affirmed that he was
not saying but for the oil SIA port that
we would have found the president of
destructive justice so I just say
there's a conflict I do have some more
questions mr. Miller there
spend a lot of talk today about firing a
special counsel and curtailing the
investigation were you ever fired mr.
Muller
what were you ever fired as special
counsel mr. motherhood no no where were
you allowed to complete your
investigation unencumbered yes and in
fact you resigned as Special Counsel
when you closed up the office in late
May 20 2019 is that correct correct
Thank You mr. Muller on April 18th the
Attorney General had held a press
conference in conjunction with the
public release of your report did
attorney general bar say anything
inaccurate either in his press
conference or his March 24th letter to
Congress summarizing the principal
conclusions of your report well what you
are not mentioning is the letter we sent
on March 27th to mr. Barr that raised
some issues and that letter speaks for
itself but then I don't see how you
could could that could be since AG bars
letter detailed the principal
conclusions of your report and you have
said before that that there wasn't
anything in that inaccurate in fact you
have this joint statement but let me let
me go on to another question mr. Millar
rather than purely relying on the
evidence provided by witnesses and
documents I think you relied a lot on
media I'd like to know how many times
you cited the Washington Post in your
report how many times I what I did the
Washington Post in your report I do not
have knowledge of that figure but I well
I don't have knowledge of that figure I
counted about 60 times how many times
did you say the New York Times I counted
no idea I counted about 75 times how
many times did you cite Fox News as were
the other two I
no idea about 25 times I've got to say
it looks like volume 2 is mostly
regurgitated times how many times did
you say the New York Times I counted
yeah no idea I counted about 75 times
how many times did you cite Fox News as
were the other two I have no idea about
25 times I've got to say it looks like
volume 2 is mostly regurgitated press
port then in a footnote a small footnote
number 7 page 15a volume 2 of your
report you wrote I quote this section
summarizes insights various news stories
not for the truth of the information
contained in the stories but rather to
place candidate Trump's response to
those stories in context since nobody
but lawyers reads footnotes are you
concerned that the American public took
the embedded news stories and maybe the
gentlelady has expired the gentlelady
from Washington mr. mallero the question
no no we're running short on time
I said the gentlelady from Washington
Thank You director Muller let's turn to
the fifth of the obstruction episodes in
your report kampala cook the embedded
news stories and maybe the gentlelady
has expired the gentlelady from
Washington mr. Miller the question no no
we're running short on time I said the
gentlelady from Washington Thank You
director Muller let's turn to the fifth
of the obstruction episodes in your
repeats in two different jurisdictions
correct correct and your office found
that after a grand jury indicted them
manna fort told gates
not to plead guilty to any charges
because quote he had talked to the
president president's personal counsel
and they were going to take care of us
is that correct that's accurate and
according to your report one day after
mana Ford's conviction on eight felony
charges quote the president said that
flipping was not fair and almost ought
to be outlawed is that correct
I'm aware of that in this context
director Muller what does it mean to
flip has somebody cooperate in a
criminal investigation and how essential
is that cooperation to any efforts to
combat crime I'm not gonna go vision on
eight felony charges quote the president
said that flipping was not fair and
almost ought to be outlawed is that
correct
I'm aware of that in this context
director Muller what does it mean to
flip has somebody cooperate in a
criminal investigation and how essential
is that cooperation to any efforts to
combat crime I'm not gonna go beyond you
shown where someone with an improper
motive encourages another person not to
cooperate with law enforcement is that
correct correct now on page 123 of
volume 2 you also discuss the
president's motive and you say that as
court proceedings move forward against
manna for president Trump quote
discussed with aides
whether and in what way Manafort might
be cooperating and weatherman affort
knew any information that would be
harmful to the president end quote is
that correct
and that was a quote from from page 123
volume 2 I have it thank you yes
and when someone tries to stop another
person from working with law enforcement
and they do it because they're worried
about what that person will say it seems
clear from what you wrote that this is a
classic definition of witness tampering
now mr. manna Ford did eventually decide
to cooperate with your office and he
entered into a plea agreement but then
he broke that agreement can you describe
what he did that caused you to tell the
court that the agreement was off I'd
refer you to the court proceedings on
that issue so in page one paint it seems
clear from what you wrote that this is a
classic definition of witness tampering
now mr. manna Fort did eventually decide
to cooperate with your office and he
entered into a plea agreement but then
he broke that agreement can you describe
what he did that caused you to tell the
court that the agreement was off I'd
refer you to the court proceedings on
that issue
so in page 1 on page 1 volume 2 that's a
director on the report yes I'm supported
and two days after you told the court
that manna fort broke his plea agreement
by lying repeatedly did President Trump
tell the press that mr. manna fort was
quote very brave because he did not flip
this is page 128 of volume 2 if it's in
the report I support it as it is volume
2 that's a director on the report yes I
support it and two days after you told
the court that manna fort broke his plea
agreement by lying repeatedly did
President Trump tell the press that mr.
manna fort was quote very brave because
he did not flip this is page 128 of
volume 2 if it's in the report I support
it as it is as it is support thank you
director Muller in your report you make
a very serious conclusion about the
evidence regarding the president's
involvement with the manna fort criminal
proceedings let me read to you from your
report evidence concerning the
president's conduct toward manna 4
indicates that the president intended to
encourage man afford to not cooperate
with the government gentleman from
Pennsylvania Thank You mr. chairman mr.
Muller mr. Mellon over here I'm sorry
mr. Muller are you familiar with the now
expired independent council statute it's
a statute under which Ken Starr was
that Ken started what I'm sorry are you
familiar with the Independent Counsel
statute are you talking about the one we
operating under now or a previous
through which Ken Starr was appointed I
am not that familiar with that but I'd
be happy to take your question
well the Clinton administration allowed
the Independent Counsel statute to
expire after ken starr's investigation
the final report requirement was a major
reason why the statute was allowed to
expire even President Clinton's AG what
we operating under now or a premium
under which Ken Starr was appointed I am
not that familiar with that but I'm
happy to take a question well the
Clinton administration allowed the
Independent Counsel statute to expire
after ken starr's investigation
the final report requirement was a major
reason why the statute was allowed to
expire even President Clinton's AG JIT
under our system we presume innocence
and we value privacy we believe that
information obtained during a criminal
investigation should in most cases be
made public only if there is an
indictment and prosecution not in a
lengthy and detailed report filed after
decision had has been made not to
prosecute the final report provides a
forum for unfairly airing a targets
dirty laundry and it also creates yet
another incentive for an independent
counsel to over investigate in order to
justify his or her tenure and to avoid
criticism that the Independent Counsel
may have left a stone unturned
again mr. Mulder those are AG Reno's
words didn't you do exactly what AG Reno
feared didn't you publish a lengthy
report unfairly airing the targets dirty
laundry without recommending charges I
disagree with that I have the chance to
be cross-examined can I just finish my
answer on that quickly I operate under
the current statute nuts didn't you do
exactly what AG Reno feared didn't you
publish a lengthy report unfairly airing
the targets dirty laundry without
recommending charges I disagree with
that your witness
I have the chance to be cross-examined
could I just finish my answer on that
quickly I operate under the current
statute given that a G bar stated
multiple times during his confirmation
hearing that he would make as much of
your report public as possible did you
write your report knowing they would
likely be shared with the public
no didn't knowing the report could
unlikely would be made public did that
alter the contents would you included I
can't speak to that
despite the expectations that your
report would be released to the public
you left out significant exculpatory
evidence in other words evidence
favorable to the president correct well
I actually would disagree with you I
think we would strove to put into the
report I think open as Michael fitori
got into that with you where he said
there was a few said there was Evans you
left out
well yeah you make a choice as to what
goes into mr. Muller isn't it true that
on page one a volume two you stay when
you're quoting the statute you had an
obligation to either prosecute or not
prosecuted well generally that is the
case
although most cases are not done in the
context of the president in this case
you made a decision not to prosecute
correct no we made a decision not to
decide whether to prosecute or not so so
essentially what your report did was
everything that AG Reno warned against I
can't agree with that characterization
well well what you did is you compiled a
nearly 450 you compiled nearly 450 pages
of the very worst information you
gathered against the target of your
investigation who happens to be the
president the United States and you did
this knowing that you were not going to
recommend charges and then the report
would be made public uh true mr. mr.
Muller as a former officer in the United
States Jag Corps I prosecuted nearly a
hundred chairs in a Baghdad courtroom
across examine the butcher of Fallujah
in defense of our Navy SEALs as a
civilian I was elected in Magisterial
District Judge in Pennsylvania so I'm
very well-versed the American legal
system the drafting in a publication of
some of the information in his report
without an indictment without
prosecution frankly flies in the face of
American justice and I find those facts
in this entire process on American are
you know the remainder of my time to my
colleague Jim Jordan mr. director Mahler
the third pfizer renewal happens a month
after your name special counsel what
role did your office play in the third
phase of renewal of Carter page no I
talked to that timing the gentleman has
expired the gentlelady from Florida
director Muller a couple of my
colleagues right here wanted to talk to
you or ask you about lies so let's talk
about lies according to your report page
9 volume 1 witnesses lied to your office
and to Congress those lies materially
impaired the investigation of Russia
interference according to your report
other than the individuals who pled
guilty to crimes based on their lying to
you and your team did other witnesses
lie to you I think there probably a
spectrum of witnesses in terms of those
who are not telling the full truth and
those are outright Liars thank you very
much outright liars it is fair to say
then that there were limits on what
evidence was available to your
investigation of both Russia election
interference and obstruction of justice
that's true it is usually in a case and
that lies by Trump campaign officials
and administration officials impede at
your investigation I would generally
agree with that thank you so much
director Muller you will be hearing more
from me in the next hearing so I yield
the balance of my time to mr. Correa
Thank You mr. Muller first of all let me
welcome you thank you for your service
to our country you were here Oh Vietnam
War vet wounded war vet we won't forget
to service to her country thank you sir
I may begin because of time limits we
have gone in depth on only five possible
episodes of obstruction there's there's
so much more and I want to focus and
another section of obstruction which is
the president's conduct concerning
Michael Flynn the president's national
security advisor in early 27
White House Council and the president
were informed that mr. Fitz we have gone
in depth on only five possible episodes
of obstruction there's there's so much
more and I want to focus and on another
section of obstruction which is the
president's conduct concerning Michael
Flynn the president's national security
adviser in early 27 the White House
Counsel and the president were informed
that mr. if we speak to that I don't
disagree with it necessarily but I'm not
going to speak to any more to that issue
thank you very much sir
Flynn resigned on February 13 2016 and
the very next day when the president was
having lunch with New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie did the president say
open quotes now that we fired Flynn the
Russia thing is over
close quote is that correct correctly
and is it true that Christie responded
by saying open quotes no way and this
Russia thing is far from over
close quote that's the way we have it in
the report thank you and after president
met with Christie later that same day at
the same day the president arranged to
meet with an FBI director James Comey
alone in the Oval Office correct correct
particularly if you have the citation to
the page 39 40 volume 2 thank you very
much and according to Comey the
president told him I hope open quote I
hope you can see your way to clear to
letting this thing go to letting Flynn
go he's a good guy and I hope he can let
it go
close quote page 40 volume 2 accurate
what did Comey understand the president
to be asking I'm not gonna get into what
was enough mr. Comey is mind Comey
understood is to be a direction because
of the president's position and the
circumstances of the one-to-one meeting
page 40 volume 2 well I understand it's
in the report and I support it as being
in the as being in the report thank you
sir even though the pub the
that are publicly denied telling call me
to drop the investigation you've found
open quote substantial evidence
corroborating commis account over the
presidents is this correct correctly the
president fired Comey on May 9th is that
correct sir I believe that's the
accurate date that's paid 77 volume 2
you found substantial evidence that the
catalyst for the president's firing of
Comey was commis open quote
unwillingness to publicly state that the
president was not personally under
investigation
I'm not going to delve more into the
details of what happened if it's in the
report
then I'm supportive because it's already
been reviewed appropriately appears in
the report and that's page 75 volume
thank you thank you and in fact the very
next day the president told the Russian
Foreign Minister open quote I just fired
the head of the FBI he was crazy a real
nutjob I face great pressure because of
Russia that's taken off I'm not under
investigation close quote is that
correct
that's what we report yes time of the
gentleman has expired thank you sir
gentleman from Virginia Thank You mr.
chairman mr. Cole mr. Muller we've heard
a lot about what you're not going to
talk about today so let's talk about
something that you should be able to
talk about the law itself the underlying
obstruction statute and your creative
legal analysis of the statutes in volume
2 particularly an interpretation of 18
USC 1512 C section 1512 C is an
obstruction of justice statute created
as part of auditing and financial
regulations for public companies and as
you write on page 164 of volume 2 this
provision was added as a floor amendment
in the Senate and explained as closing a
certain loophole with respect to
document shredding and to read the
statute whoever corruptly alters
destroys mutilates or conceals a record
document or other object or attempts to
do so with the intent to impair the
object's integrity or availability for
use in an official proceeding or
otherwise obstructs influences or
impedes and
official proceeding or attempts to do so
shall we find under the statue or
imprisoned not more than 20 years of
both your analysis and application of
the statute proposes to give Clause C to
a much broader interpretation than
commonly used first your analysis
proposes to read closely to an isolation
reading it as a free-standing
all-encompassing provision prohibiting
any act influencing a proceeding if done
with an improper motive and second your
analysis of the statute to apply this
week being proposes to apply the
sweeping prohibition to lawful acts
taken by public officials exercising
their discretionary powers if those acts
influence a proceeding so mr. mowett
asked you in analyzing the obstruction
you state that you recognize that the
Department of Justice and the courts
have not definitively resolved these
issues correct correct you'd agree that
not everyone in the Justice Department
agreed with your legal theory of the
obstruction of justice statute correct
I'm not going to be involved in
discussion on on that at this juncture
in fact the Attorney General himself
disagrees with your interpretation of
the law correct I leave that to the
Attorney General to identify and you
would agree that prosecutor sometimes
incorrectly applied the law correct I
would have to agree with that one and
members of your legal team in fact if
had convictions overturned because they
were based on an incorrect legal theory
correct I don't know to what you advert
we've all well in time and one of
trenches trying cases have not won every
one of those cases well let me ask you
about one in particular one of your top
prosecutors Andrew Weissman obtain a
conviction against auditing firm Arthur
Andersen lower court which was
subsequently overturned in a unanimous
Supreme Court decision that rejected the
legal theory advanced by Weissman
correct well I'm not gonna get in at
delhi under well let me read from that
maybe I just remember I just finished
yes answer to say that I'm not going to
be getting involved in a discussion on
that I will refer you to that citation
that you gave me at the outset for the
lengthy discussion on just what you're
talking about and to the extent that I
have say anything to say about it it is
what we have already put into the report
on that and I am reading from your
report when discussing this section now
I'll read from the decision of the
Supreme Court unanimously reversing mr.
Weissman when he said indeed as it
it's striking how little culpability the
instructions required for example the
jury was told that even if petitioner
honestly and sincerely believed as
conduct was lawful the jury could
convict the instructions also diluted
the meaning of corruptly such that it
covered innocent conduct I've limited
time your report takes the broadest
possible reading of this provision in
applying it to the president's official
acts and I'm concerned about the
implications of your theory for over
criminalizing conduct by public
officials and private citizens alike so
to emphasize how broad your theory of
liability is I want to ask you about a
few examples on October 11 2015
during the FBI investigation in the
Hillary Clinton's used of a private
email server
President Obama said I don't think it
posed a national security problem and he
later said I can tell you that this is
not a situation in which American
implications of your theory for over
criminalizing conduct by public
officials and private citizens alike so
to emphasize how broad your theory of
liability is I want to ask you about a
few examples on October 11th 2015 during
the FBI investigation into Hillary
Clinton's used to private email server
President Obama said I don't think it
posed a national security problem and he
later said I can tell you that this is
not a situation in which America is a
number units I have very low at a time
in August 2015 a very senior DOJ
official called FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe expressing concern that
FBI agents were still openly pursuing
the Clinton Foundation probe the DOJ
official was apparently very pissed off
quote-unquote McCabe questioned this
official asking are you telling me I
need to shut down a badly predicated
investigation to which the official
replied of course not this seems to be a
clear example of somebody within the
executive branch attempting to influence
an s behind this investigation so under
your theory couldn't that person be
charged with obstruction as long as a
prosecutor could come up with a
potentially corrupt corrupt motive I
refer you to our lengthy dissertation on
exactly those issues and fears in the
esta Gatien to which the official
replied of course not this seems to be a
clear example of somebody within the
executive branch attempting to influence
an S V ID this investigation so under
your theory couldn't that person be
charged with obstruction as long as a
prosecutor could come up with a
potentially corrupt corrupt motive I
refer you to our lengthy dissertation on
exactly those issues and appears in the
five minutes so that we can complete our
work as close to that timeframe as
possible and I recognize the gentlelady
from Pennsylvania Thank You director
Muller um I want to ask you some
questions about the president's
statements regarding advanced knowledge
of the WikiLeaks dumps so the President
refused to sit down with your
investigators for an in-person interview
correct correct so the only answers we
have two questions from the president
are contained in Appendix C to your
report correct okay so looking at
Appendix C on page five you asked the
president over a dozen questions about
whether he had knowledge that WikiLeaks
possessed or might possess the emails
that were stolen by the Russians I
apologize so the only answers we have
two questions from the president are
contained in Appendix C to your report
okay so looking at Appendix C on page
five you asked the president over a
dozen questions about whether he had
knowledge that WikiLeaks possessed or
might possess the emails that were
stolen by the Russians I apologize is
that correct you ask those questions
okay in February of this year mr.
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
testified to Congress under oath that
quote mr. Trump knew from Roger stone in
advance about the WikiLeaks drop of
emails and quote that's a matter of
public record isn't it
well are you referring to the report or
some other public crisis was testimony
before Congress by mr. Cohen do you know
what he told no I'm not familiar with it
it's explicitly familiar with what he
testified to before Congress okay let's
look in an event described on page 18 of
volume 2 of your report now according
and we're gonna put it up in a slide I
think according to deputy campaign
manager Rick Gates in the summer of 2016
he and candidate Trump were on the way
to an airport shortly after WikiLeaks
released its first set of stolen emails
and Gates told your investigators that
candidate Trump was on a phone call and
when the call ended Trump told gates
that more releases of
damaging information would be coming and
quote do you recall that from the report
if it's in the report I've supported
okay and that's on page 18 of volume 2
now on page 77 of volume 2 your report
also stated quote in addition some
witnesses said that Trump privately
sought information about future wiki
leak releases end quote is that correct
correct now in Appendix C where the
president did answer some written
questions he said quote I do not recall
discussing wiki leaks with him nor do I
recall being aware of mr. stone having
discussed wiki leaks with individuals
associated with my campaign end quote is
that correct
releases end quote is that correct
correct now in Appendix C where the
president did answer some written
questions he said quote I do not recall
discussing wiki leaks with him nor do I
recall being aware of mr. stone having
discussed wiki leaks with individuals
associated with my campaign
end quote is that correct I have it's
from the report it is correct okay so is
it fair to say the president denied ever
discussing wiki leaks with mr. stone and
denied being aware that anyone
associated with his campaign discussed
wiki leaks with Stone I'm sorry could
you repeat that one is it fair then that
the president denied knowledge of
himself or anyone else discussing wiki
leaks dumps with mr. yes yes I was asked
to give my input on what it would take
to do the job which triggered the
interview you're talking about so you
don't recall on May 16th 2017 that you
interviewed with the president regarding
the FBI director job I interviewed with
the president and director knows about
the job and not about me applying for
the job so so your statement here today
is that she didn't interview to apply
for the FBI director job that's correct
so it did you tell the vice president at
the FBI director position would be the
one job that you would come back to for
don't recall that one you don't recall
that no okay
given you 22 months of investigation
tens of million dollars spent and
millions of documents reviewed in here
today is that you didn't interview
to apply for the FBI director job that's
correct so it did you tell the
vice-president at the FBI director
position would be the one job that you
would come back to for don't recall that
one you don't recall that no okay
giving you 22 months of investigation
tens of million dollars spent and
millions of documents reviewed did June
medaling was outside your purview but
the the impact of that meddling was
undertaken by other agencies okay you
stated in your opening statement that
you would not get into the details of
the steal dossier however multiple times
and volume two on page 23 27 and 28
you mentioned the unverified allegations
how long did it take you to to reach the
conclusion that it was unverified I'm
not gonna speak to that it's in it's
actually in your report multiple times
that it's unverified and you're telling
me that you're not willing to tell us
how you came to the conclusion that it
was unverified true when did you become
aware that the unverified steal dossier
was included in the FISA application to
spy on Carter page I'm sorry what was he
what was the question when did you
become aware that the unverified steal
dossier was intended was included in the
FISA applications Spinal Carter page I'm
not gonna speak to that your team
interviewed Christopher Steele is that
correct not gonna get into that you can
tell this committee as to whether or not
you interview crystal Steele in a 22
month investigation with 18 lawyers as I
said at the outset that is one of those
one of the investigations that is is
being handled by others in the
Department of Justice but you're here
testifying about this investigation
today and I am asking you directly did
any members of your team or did you
interview Christopher Steele in the
course of your investigation and I'm not
going to answer that question sir you
had two years to investigate not once
did you consider it worthy to
investigate how an under unverified
document it was paid for by a political
opponent was used to obtain a warrant to
spy on the opposition political campaign
did you do any investigation and that
was it would not accept your
characterization of what occurred what
would you what would be your target
speech any more to it so you can't speak
any more to it but you're not going to
agree with my characterization is that
correct
yes the fisa application makes reference
to source one who was Christopher Steele
the author of the steel dossier the FISA
application says nothing sources ones
reason for conducting the research into
Canada at once ties Russia based on
sources one previous reporting history
with FBI whereby source one provided
reliable information the FBI the FBI
believes source one's reporting here and
to be credible do you believe the FBI's
representation that source one's
reporting was credible to be accurate
I'm not gonna answer so you're not going
to respond to any of the questions
regarding Christopher steel or your
interviews with them well I said at the
outset this morning that was one of the
investigations that I could not speak to
well I don't understand how if you
interviewed an individual in the purview
of this investigation that you're
testifying to us today that you've
closed that investigation how that's not
within your purview to tell us about
that investigation and who you
interviewed
I have nothing dad okay well the I can
guarantee that the American people want
to know and I'm and I'm very hopeful and
glad that AG bar is looking into this
and the Inspector General is looking
into this because you're unwilling to
answer the questions of the American
people as it relates to the very basis
of this investigation into the President
and a very basis of this individual who
you did interview you're just refusing
to answer those questions can Camp the
president fire the FBI director at any
time without reason under the article 1
of the Constitution yes article 2 yes
that's correct
can't he also fire you as Special
Counsel at any time without any reason I
believe that to be the case under
article so well you said without any
reason I know that Special Counsel can
be fired but I'm not certain it extends
to for whatever reason is given well and
you've testified that you weren't fired
you were able to complete your
investigation in full is that correct
I'm not gay add to what I've stated
before my time is expired
his time has expired the gentlelady from
Pennsylvania
Texas Thank You mr. chairman and thank
you mr. Buller for being with us the
south this have not close to the
afternoon now director Mullen I would
like to ask you about the president's
answers relating to Roger stone Roger
stone was indicted for multiple federal
crimes and indictment alleges that mr.
stone discussed future wiki leaks email
releases with the Trump campaign
understanding there's a gag order on the
stone case I will keep my question is
restricted to publicly available
information mr. soulsand I would just
say at the outside I don't mean to
disrupt you but I'm not I would like
some demarcation of that which is
applicable to this but also in such a
way that it does not hinder the other
prosecution is taking place in DC I
understand that I'm only going to be
talking about the questions that you
asked in writing to the president
document we're late to mr. stone mr.
stones indictment states among other
things the following quote stone was
contacted by senior Trump officials to
inquire about future releases of
organization one organization went being
WikiLeaks the indictment continues quote
stone thereafter told the Trump campaign
about potential future releases of
damaging material by WikiLeaks so in
short the indictment alleges that stone
was asked by the Trump campaign to get
information about more WikiLeaks
releases and that stone in fact did tell
the can't Trump campaign about potential
future releases correct yes ma'am I see
you're quoting from the indictment and
even though the indictment is a public
document I feel uncomfortable discussing
anything having to do with the stone
prosecution right D yep and diamond is
is a record in my poll we pulled it off
of the well well turning back to the
president's answers to your questions in
on this very subject the president
denied ever discussing future we weekly
leaks releases with stone and tonight
knowing whether anyone else on his
champagne had those discussions with
stone if you had learned that other
witnesses put us putting aside the
president if other witnesses had lied to
you investigators in response to
Pacific's questions whether he whether
in writing or in an interview
could they be charged with false
statement crimes I'm I'm not going to
speculate I think you're asking for me
to speculate let's put it more specific
what if I have made a false statement to
an investigator on your team could I go
to jail for up to five years yes yes
although there's it's Congress oh well
that's the point though isn't it that no
one is above the law not you not the
Congress it's certainly not the
President and I think it's just
troubling to have to hear some of these
statement to an investigator on your
team could I go to jail for up to five
years yes yes although it's Congress
well that's the point though isn't it
that no one is above the law not you not
the Congress it's certainly not the
president and I think it's just
troubling to have to hear some of these
things the gentleman from North Dakota
is recognized mr. Muller how many people
did you fire how many people on your
staff to fire during the course of the
investigation how many people did you
fire I'm not a discuss that you fired
according the inspector general's report
attorney number two was let go and we
know Peter Strock was let go correct yes
and there may have been other persons on
other issues that have been either
transfer or fire Peter struck testified
before this committee on July 12 2018
that he was fired because you were
concerned about preserving the
appearance of Independence you agreed
this testimony I say that again if you
could he said he was fired at least
partially because you were you were
worried about a concern about preserving
the appearance of Independence with the
special counsels investigation do you
agree with that statement this statement
was by home.you distraught at this
hearing I know I have not familiar with
that did you fire him because you were
worried about the appearance of
Independence of the end of
investigation no he was a transferred as
a result of instances involving Tex did
you agree that do you agree that your
office did not only have an obligation
to operate with him independence but to
operate with the appearance of
independence as well absolutely we
strove to do that over the two years
Andrew rice but part of that was making
certain that Andrew Weissman's one of
your top attorneys yes
did Wiseman have a role in selecting
other members of your team yeah it's
some role but not a major role Andrew
Weissman attended Hillary Clinton's
election night party did you know that
before after he came on to the team no
what I found that out on January 30th
2017 Weissman wrote an email to Deputy
Attorney General Yates stating I am so
proud and in awe regarding her
disobeying a direct order from the
president
did Weissman disclose that email to you
before he joined the team yeah I'm not
going to talk about that is that not a
conflict of interest another guy not
going to talk about that are you aware
that Miss Jean Erie represented Hillary
Clinton in litigation regarding personal
emails originated originating from
Clinton's time as Secretary of State
yes did you know that before she came on
the tow Erin's elderly the guy sitting
next to you represented Justin Cooper a
Clinton aide who destroyed one of
Clinton's mobile devices and you must be
aware by now that six of your lawyers
donated $12,000 directly to Hillary
Clinton I'm not even talking about the
49,000 they donated other Democrats just
the donations to the opponent who is the
target of your investigation can I speak
for a second to the hiring practices
sure we strove to hire those individuals
that could do the job okay I've been in
this business for almost 25 years and in
those 25 years I have not had occasion
once to ask somebody about their
political affiliation it is not done
what I care about is the capability of
the individual to do the job and do the
job quickly and seriously and with
integrity but that's what I'm saying mr.
Muller this isn't just about you being
able to vote your team this is about
knowing that the day you accepted this
role you had to be aware no matter what
this report concluded half of the
country was going to be scheduled
skeptical of your team's findings and
that's why we have recusal laws that
define bias and perceived bias for this
very reason 28 United States Code 5
1:8 specifically lists not just
political conflict of interest but the
appearance of political contracts a
conflict of interest it's just simply
not enough that you vouch for your team
the interested does demand that no
perceived bias exists I can't imagine a
single prosecutor or judge that I have
ever appeared in front of would be
comfortable with these circumstances
where over half of the prosecutorial
team had a direct relationship to the
opponent of the person being
investigated let me know the fact that I
put on the table and that is we hired 19
lawyers over the period of time of those
19 lawyers 14 of them were transferred
from elsewhere the Department of Justice
lb 5 came from outside and hell did not
had a direct relationship political or
personal with the opponent of the person
you were investigating and that's my
point
I wonder if not a single word and this
entire report was changed but rather the
only difference was we switched Hillary
Clinton and President Trump if Peter
Strock had texted those terrible things
about Hillary Clinton instead of
president Truong if a team of lawyers
worked for donated thousands of dollars
- and went to Trump's Trump's parties
instead of Clinton's I don't think we'd
be here trying to prop up an obstruction
allegation my colleagues would have
spent the last four months accusing your
team of being bought and paid for by the
Trump campaign and we couldn't trust a
single word of this report they would
still be accusing the president of
conspiracy with Russia and they would be
accusing your team of aiding and
embedding in that with that conspiracy
and with that I yield back gentleman
yields back the gentleman from Colorado
dr. Mohler thank you for your service to
our country I'd like to talk to you
about one of the other incidents of
obstruction and that's the evidence in
your report showing the president
directing his son and his communications
director to issue a false public
statement in June of 2017 about a
meeting between his campaign and Russian
individuals at Trump Tower in June of
2016 according to your report mr. Trump
jr. was the only Trump associate who
participated in that meeting and who
declined to be voluntarily interviewed
by your office is that correct did mr.
Trump jr. or his counsel ever
communicate to your office any intent to
invoke his Fifth Amendment right against
self-incrimination
you did post written questions to the
president about his knowledge of the
Trump Tower meeting you included also
asked him about whether or not he had
directed a false press statement the
president did not answer it all that
question correct I don't have it in
front of me I can represent to you that
Appendix C specifically c-13 states as
much according to page 100 of volume 2
of your report your investigation found
that hope Hicks the president's
communications director in June of 2017
was shown emails that set up the Trump
Tower meeting and she told your office
that she was quote shocked by the emails
because they looked quote really bad
true do you have a citation sure it's
page 100 of volume 2 while you're
flipping to that page director molar I
will also tell you that according to
page 99 of volume 2 those emails in
question stated according to your report
that the crown prosecutor of Russia had
offered to provide the Trump campaign
with some official documents and
information that would incriminate
Hillary and her dealings with Russia as
part of Russia and its government's
support for mr. Trump Trump jr.
responded if it's what you say I love it
and he Kushner and mana 4 met with the
Russian attorneys and several other
Russian individuals at Trump Tower on
June 9th 2016 and quote correct
generally accurate isn't it true that
Miss Hicks told your office that she
went multiple times to the president to
quote urge him that they should be fully
transparent about the June 9th meeting
end quote but the president met with the
Russian attorneys and several other
Russian individuals at Trump Tower on
June 9th 2016 end quote
correct generally accurate isn't it true
that Miss Hicks told your office that
she went multiple times to the president
to quote urge him that they should be
fully transparent about the June 9th
meeting end quote but the president
option end quote because Trump juniors
statement to the New York Times quote
said too much we're in a 1/2 H one
hundred two of volume two okay correct
just check one thing yes and according
to miss Hicks the president still
directed her to say the meeting was only
about Russian adoption correct yes
despite knowing that to be untrue Thank
You director Muller I yield back the
balance of my on time mr. Muller you've
been asked over here on the on the far
right sir you've been asked a lot of
questions here today to be frank you
performed as most of us expected you've
stuck closely to your report and you
have declined to answer many of our
questions on both sides as the closer
for the Republican side I know you're
glad to get to the close I want to
summarize the highlights of what we have
heard and what we know you spent two
years and nearly 30 million taxpayer
dollars and unlimited resources to
prepare a nearly 450 page report which
you describe today as very thorough
millions of Americans today maintain
genuine concerns about your work in
large part because of the infamous and
widely publicized bias of your
investigating team members which we now
know included 14 Democrats and 0
Republicans campaign finance reports
later showed that team excuse me it's my
time that team of Democrat investigators
you hired donated more than $60,000 to
the Hillary Clinton campaign and other
Democratic candidates your team also
included Peter struck and Lisa Paige
which had been doesn't discuss today and
they had the lowest tech lurid text
messages that confirmed they openly
mocked and hated Donald Trump and his
supporters and they vowed to take him
out mr. Radcliffe asked you earlier this
morning quote can you give me an example
other than Donald Trump where the
Justice Department determined that an
investigated person was not exonerated
because their innocence was not
conclusively determined unquote you
answered I cannot sir that is
unprecedented the president believed
from the very beginning that you and
your special counsel team had serious
conflicts this is stated in the report
and acknowledged by everybody and yet
President Trump cooperated fully with
the investigation he knew he had done
nothing wrong and he encouraged all
witnesses to cooperate with the
investigation and produced more than 1.4
million pages of information and allowed
over 40 witnesses who were directly
affiliated with the White House for his
campaign your report acknowledges on
page 61 volume 2 that he
volume of evidence exists of the
president telling many people privately
quote the president was concerned about
the impact of the Russian investigation
on his ability to govern and to address
important foreign relations issues and
even matters of national security and on
page 174 volume to your report also
acknowledges that the Supreme Court has
held quote the president's removal
powers are at their Zenith with respect
to principal officers that is officers
who must be appointed by the President
and who report to him directly
the president's exclusive and
illimitable power of removal of those
principal officers furthers the
president's ability to ensure that the
laws are faithfully executed unquote and
that would even include the Attorney
General look in spite of all of that
nothing ever happened to stop or impede
your special counsels investigation
nobody was fired by the president
nothing was curtailed and the
investigation continued unencumbered for
22 long months as you finally concluded
in volume 1 the evidence quote did not
establish that the president was
involved in an underlying crime related
to Russian election interference unquote
and the evidence quote did not establish
that the president or those close to him
were involved in any Russian
conspiracies or had an unlawful
relationship with any Russian official
unquote over those 22 long months that
your investigation dragged along the
president became increasingly frustrated
as many of the American people did with
its effects on our country and his
ability to govern he vented about this
to his lawyer and his closest associates
and he even shared his frustrations as
we all know on Twitter but while the
president's social media accounts might
have influenced some in the media or the
opinion of some of the American people
none of those audiences were targets or
witnesses in your investigation the
president never affected anybody's
testimony he never demanded to in the
investigation or demanda that you be
terminated and he never misled Congress
the DOJ or the special counsel those sir
are undisputed facts there will be a lot
of discussion I predict today and great
frustration throughout the country about
the fact that you wouldn't answer any
questions here about the origins of this
targets or witnesses in your
investigation the president never
affected anybody's testimony he never
demanded to in the investigation or
demanded that you be terminated and he
never misled Congress the DOJ or the
special counsel those sir are undisputed
facts there will be a lot of discussion
I predicted
great frustration throughout the country
about the fact that you wouldn't answer
any questions here about the origins of
this I'd you today to tell them they
should impeach the president but the one
thing you have said very clearly today
is that your report is complete and
thorough and you completely agree with
and stand by its recommendations and all
of its content is that right true mr.
Muller one last important question your
report does not recommend impeachment
does it I'm not gay talked about
recommendations it does not conclude
that impeach would be appropriate here
I'm not going to talk about about that
that issue that's one of the many things
you wouldn't talk about today but I
think we can all draw our own
conclusions I do thank you for your
service to the country and I'm glad this
charade will come to an end soon and we
can get back to the important business
of this committee with its broad
jurisdiction of so many important issues
for the country without I yield back
gentleman yields back I want to announce
that our intent was to conclude this
hearing at around 11:45 all of the
Republican members have now asked their
questions but we have a few remaining
Democratic members they would be
limiting their questions so with
director Moe's indulgence we expect to
finish within 15 minutes the gentlelady
from Georgia is recognized Thank You mr.
chairman and thank you director Muller
your investigations of the Russian
attack on our democracy of obstruction
of justice justice were extraordinarily
productive in under two years you
charged at least 37 people or entities
with crimes you convicted seven
individuals five of whom were top Trump
campaign or White House aides charges
remain pending against more than two
dozen Russian persons or entities and
against others now let me start with
those five Trump campaign or
administration aids that you convicted
would you agree with me that they are
pom Anna for president Trump's campaign
manager Rick gates president Trump's
deputy campaign manager Michael Flynn
president Trump's former national
security adviser Michael Cohen the
president's personal attorney George
papadopolis president Trump's former
campaign foreign policy advisor correct
and the sixth trumpet so shi'ite will
fate will face trial later this year
correct and that person would be Roger
stone
right right thank you I'm not certain
what you said by stone but he is in
another court system is I indicated
before I don't want to discuss correct
thank you and there are many other
charges as well correct right so sir I
just want to thank you so much in my
limited time today for your team the
work that you did in your dedication in
less than two years your team was able
to uncover an incredible amount of
information related to Russia's attack
on our elections and to obstruction of
justice and there's still more that we
have to learn despite facing unfair
attacks by the President and even here
today your work has been substantive and
fair the work has laid the critical
foundation for our investigation and for
that I thank you I thank you with that I
yield back the balance of my ten Latios
back the gentleman from Arizona Thank
You director Muller I'm disappointed
that some have questioned your motives
throughout this process and I want to
take a moment to remind the American
people of who you are and your exemplary
service to our country you are thank you
I thank you with that I yield back the
balance of my ten radio's back the
gentleman from Arizona Thank You
director Muller I'm disappointed that
some have questioned your motives
throughout this process and I want to
take a moment to remind the American
people of who you are and your exemplary
service to our country you armed again
had the honor to do so under whose it my
mistake under whose administration did
you serve as the assistant attorney
general in charge of the do J's Criminal
Division which president yeah that would
be George Bush one that is correct
President George HW Bush after that you
took a job at a prestigious law firm and
after only a couple years you did
something extraordinary you left that
lucrative position to re-enter public
service prosecuting homicides here in
Washington see is that correct correct
when you were named director of the FBI
which president
first appointed you Bush and the Senate
confirmed you with a vote of 98 US law
firm and after only a couple years you
did something extraordinary you left
that lucrative position to re-enter
public service prosecuting homicides
here in Washington DC is that correct
correct when you were named director of
the FBI which president first appointed
you bush and the Senate confirmed you
with a vote of 98 when you were asked in
2017 to take the job as special counsel
the President had just fired FBI
director James Comey the Justice
Department and the FBI were in turmoil
you must have known there would be an
extraordinary challenge why did you
accept I'm not gonna get into that's a
little bit off track some people have
attacked the political motivations of
your team even suggested your
investigation was a witch-hunt when you
consider people to join your team did
you ever even once ask about their
political affiliation never once in your
entire career as a law enforcement
official have you ever made a hiring
decision based upon a person period some
people have attacked the political
motivations of your team even suggest
that your investigation was a witch-hunt
when you consider people to join your
team did you ever even once ask about
their political affiliation never once
in your entire career as a law
enforcement official have you ever made
a hiring decision based upon a person
issue sir you're a patriot and clear to
me and reading your report and listening
your testimony today
you acted fairly with restraint there
were circumstances where you could have
filed charges against other people
mentioned the report but you declined
not every prosecutor does that certainly
in a one on a witch-hunt
the attacks made against you and your
team intensified because your report is
damning and I believe you did uncover
substantial evidence of high crimes and
misdemeanors let me also say something
else that you were right about the only
remedy for this situation is for
Congress to take action I yield back
gentleman yields back the gentlelady
from Pennsylvania good morning director
mother Muller Madeline Dean
Oh gotcha sorry for high crimes and
misdemeanors let me also say something
else that you were right about the only
remedy for this situation is for
Congress to take action I yield back
gentleman yields back the gentlelady
from Pennsylvania good morning director
mother Muller
Madelene Dean Oh got you sorry report
accurately summarized this offices work
and conclusions and quote I have to say
that the letter itself speaks for itself
and those were your words in that letter
continuing with your letter you wrote to
the Attorney General that quote the
summary letter letter that the
department sent to Congress and released
to the public late in the afternoon of
March 24th did not fully capture the
context nature and substance of this
office's work and conclusions end quote
is that correct
again I rely on the letter itself for
its terms thank you what was it about
the reports context nature substance
that the Attorney General's letter did
not capture I think we captured that in
the March 27th responsive letter and
this is from the 27th letter what were
some of the specifics that you thought
direct you to the letter itself okay I
you finished that letter by saying there
is now public confusion about critical
aspects as a result of our investigation
could you tell us specifically some of
the public confusion you identified not
generally again I go back to the letter
and letter speaks for itself and could
attorney general Barr have avoided
public confusion if he had released your
summaries and executive introduction in
summaries I don't feel comfortable
speculating on that shifting to May 30th
the Attorney General in an interview
with CBS News said that you could have
reached quote you could have reached a
decision as to whether it was criminal
activity and quote on the part of the
president did the Attorney General or
his staff ever tell you that he thought
you should make a decision on whether
the president engaged in criminal
activity
I'm not going to speak
what the Attorney General was thinking
or saying if the Attorney General had
directed you or ordered you to make a
decision on whether the president
engaged in criminal activity would you
have so done can't answer that question
in the vacuum director Muller again I
thank you for being here I agree with
your March 27th letter there was public
confusion and the president took full
advantage of that confusion by falsely
claiming your report found no
obstruction let us be clear your report
did not exonerate the president instead
it provided substantial evidence of
obstruction of justice leaving Congress
to do its duty we shall shall not shrink
from that duty I yield back the
gentlelady yields back mr. chairman mr.
Chairman I have a point of inquiry over
on your left was the point of this
hearing to get mr. Muller to recommend
impeachment that is not a fair point of
inquiry the gentlelady from Florida is
recognized chairman wait right normal
around the chairman to your point the
gentlelady is recognized
we're coming here you're a patriot I
want to refer you now to volume 2 page
158 you wrote that quote the president's
efforts to influence the investigation
were mostly unsuccessful but that is
largely because the persons who
surrounded the president declined to
carry out orders or accede to his
request is that right
that is accurate and that is what we
found and you're basically referring to
senior advisors who disobeyed the
president's orders like White House
Counsel Don Magan former Trump campaign
manager Corey Lewandowski is that right
well we have not specified persons
Pechanga
well in in page 158 White House Counsel
done magan quote did not tell the acting
Attorney General that the special
counsel must be removed but was instead
prepared to resign over the president's
orders you also explained that an
attempt to obstruct justice does not
have to succeed to be a crime right true
simply attempting to obstruct justice
can be a crime correct yes
so even though the president's aides
refused to carry out his orders to
interfere with your investigation that
is not a defense to obstruction of
justice by this president is it I'm not
gonna speculate so to reiterate simply
trying to obstruct justice can be a
crime correct yes and you say that the
president's efforts to influence the
investigation were quote mostly
unsuccessful and that's because not all
of his efforts were unsuccessful right
are you reading into what I was gonna
ask you if you could just tell me which
ones you had in mind
as successful when you wrote that
sentence yeah
quote mostly unsuccessful and that's
because not all of his efforts were
unsuccessful right are you reading into
what what we've written in the report I
was gonna ask you if you could just tell
me which ones you had in mind as
successful when you wrote that sentence
accurate recitation from the from report
right and and on page 158 again I think
it's important for everyone to note that
the president's conduct had a
significant change when he realized that
it was the investigations were conducted
to investigate his obstruction acts so
in other words when the American people
are deciding whether the president
committed obstruction of justice they
need to look at all of the president's
conduct and overall pattern of behaviors
that correct I don't disagree
thank you dr. Mohler director Muller
doctor also I'll designate that too I
have certainly made up my mind about
whether we what we have reviewed today
meets the elements of obstruction
including whether there was corrupt
intent and what is clear is that anyone
else including some members of Congress
would have been charged with crimes
these acts we would not have allowed
this behavior from any of the previous
44 presidents we should not allow it now
or for the future to protect our
democracy and yes we will continue to
investigate because as you clearly say
it at the end of your report no one is
above the law I yield back my time
gentlelady yields back the gentlelady
from Texas director Muller you wrote in
your report that you quote determined
not to make a traditional prosecutorial
judgment end quote
was that in part because of an opinion
by the Department of Justice Office of
Legal Counsel that a sitting president
can't be charged with a crime yes
director Muller at your May 29th 2019
press conference you explained that
quote the opinion says that the
Constitution requires a process other
than the criminal justice system to
formally accuse a sitting president of
wrongdoing end quote
that process other than the criminal
justice system for accusing a president
of wrongdoing is that impeachment in
your report you also wrote that you did
not want to quote potentially preempt
constitutional processes for addressing
presidential misconduct end quote for
the non lawyers in the room what did you
mean by quote potentially preempt
constitutional processes I'm not going
to try to explain that that actually is
coming from page one of volume two in
the footnote is the the reference to
this
what are those constitutional processes
I think I heard you mention at least one
impeachment correct I'm not going to
comment okay that is one of the
constitutional processes listed in the
report in the footnote in volume 2 your
report documents the many ways the
president sought to interfere with your
investigation and you state and
report on page 10 volume 2 that with a
correct I'm not gonna comment ok that is
one of the constitutional processes
listed in the report in the footnote in
volume 2 your report documents the many
ways the president sought to interfere
with your investigation and you state in
your report on page 10 volume 2 that
with a it interferes the importance of
the process the Constitution requires to
quote formally accuse a sitting
president of wrongdoing as you cited in
the report and in this and this hearing
has been very helpful to this committee
as it exercises its constitutional duty
to determine whether to recommend
articles of impeachment against the
president I agree with you director
Muller that we all have a vital role in
holding this president accountable for
his actions more than that I believe we
in Congress have a duty to demand
accountability and safeguard one of our
nation's highest principles that no one
is above the law from everything that I
have heard you say here today it's I
agree with you director Muller that we
all have a vital role in holding this
president accountable for his actions
more than that I believe we in Congress
have a duty to demand accountability and
safeguard one of our nation's highest
principles that no one is above the law
from everything that I have heard you
say here today it should get in our time
after this was first developed as we did
bill to get in time our side got our
five minutes in also mr. Malla thank you
for being here and I joined the chairman
and thank you for being here thank you
director Muller we thank you for
attending today's hearing before we
conclude I ask everyone to please remain
seated and quiet while the egg while the
witness exits the room
[Music]